what is going on there citizens of the
recheck Nation we are back for the
Mandalorian season three finale John how
are you you excited I am man Delirious
with excitement Greg work play Michael
you excited yes oh yeah don't want to
try to compete don't even try to compete
yeah ladies and gentlemen yeah I got it
I was late you know what to do use the
force to leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also thank you to
everyone who has joined us on our
patreon page especially with the show
we've got a bunch of other stuff to
offer over there as well I'm excited
we're all into this I got some new comfy
pants speaking of which we got a sponsor
today Greg roll that special sponsorship
ad thank you to me on these for
sponsoring this video man I've been
wanting to work with them for a long
time now now obviously we here at the
reject Nation love to rock apparel that
resembles the things we love to talk
about the most because the clothes we
rock off and feel like a reflection of
our identity not just who we are on the
surface but who we are underneath the
surface see what I did there so even
though right now Gregory over here is
wearing a very soothing meandi shirt I'm
taking the next step forward with below
the waist clothing featuring Rocket
Raccoon and Groot from Guardians of the
Galaxy of course this collection is also
limited edition so if you like what you
see you better hop on it before it's all
gone all right I'm gonna get real with
you guys I'm a married man my wife knows
I don't mind just walking around the
house with my pants off and I like to
see your cute smile when she sees me in
these as much as I like the look of them
I always really care to be comfortable
because comfort in what I'm wearing just
makes me feel a lot more relaxed to be
on camera and it's just like that in
real life so now I feel like my identity
and comfort package is now complete I'm
by no means a clothes expert but people
will attest I'm kind of picky when it
comes to kind of fabric I put against my
body and this clothes are just so soft
even the shorts are so soft these have
been extremely comfortable for just
regular day-to-day activities lounging
around the house and even exercise you
guys even know there's some videos that
you've already seen where I've been
wearing them the whole time because why
would you it'd be a little weird for me
to announce what underwear I was wearing
at the time on top of that too you guys
who watch regularly know I'm usually
liking sweats or pajama pants and
undoubtedly these lounge pants here not
only look cool but my God these are now
without question the most comfortable
soothing pants I have ever worn on
camera so miani's of course is undies
socks loungewear and a bunch more with
sizing ranging from extra small to 4XL
yeah rejection the hype is real they
have a guarantee that if you are not
impressed with me undies your first pair
on the house that is a promise so to get
25 off your first order plus free
standard shipping go to meandies.com
rejects once again that's meandies.com
rejects thank you again to me undies
seriously thank you for sponsoring this
video
I never subscribed to the whole there's
a spy amongst this Theory I thought that
was just spies plural
up there use the capital ship as a deep
coin we can't beat them in the air
I'm entering up for atmosphere but I
have my order oh boy
I've
got a bad feeling about the fleet up
there
hey you got a POV yeah
oh nicely done
oh
wow
this is a flame retardant Cape
that punch strong punch there yes
yes
no I almost forgot my God
you're a negligent parents
help me up
Ellie
Gideon
this will never end
kill moth Gideon we escape to the
surface I know what we can hold up let's
go this way I don't trust him
everyone's a spy everyone's a spy
they're all working from off Gideon
high interceptors are gorgeous
it's locked off shots have been amazing
their capital ship will soon be
destroyed
but the Mandalorian has escaped
shall we engage
no I'll take care of him myself
I'm very impressed at how they somehow
made him scarier whoever does the
microphones in this universe A Plus or
five come in R5
R5 I'm counting on you
good luck we're all counting on you
Droid off mouse droids yeah it is
extraordinary how much character an
Astromech has
good job buddy
oh they're launching fighters to destroy
The Fleets both the gauntlets and send
all available troops down as
reinforcements screenshot
I'll take care of the cruiser everyone
go move okay ax wolves
this is so freaking cool
Wowie
come on R5
buddy
I mean let me let me in let me out
single-handedly do this never
underestimate acts freaking wolves
oh
armor is gonna save his ass
wowie I don't know
hopefully
armor M.I.A there's some barrier Shields
I'm gonna need you to deactivate them
one at a time on my command yes sir
Brooks
I love this Phantom Menace reference
right here deactivate the first shield
oh my God it's like poetry
it rhymes
oh dark Troopers suck
you should pull one into a corner and
steal their armor
yeah honestly worked for Han and Luke
next field
this is really cool it's a good steak
oh come on buddy
these guys really suck it's like me with
sock and Boppers it's more fun than a
pillow fight oh next shoe I thought I
was equipping weapons like a video game
exactly
thank you
that is our best car Shield
oh boy Mouse cop
this is an excellent physical comedy
from the Droid
there we go
yeah I'm working over here
Amanda Wick
oh my God
what the hell are you gonna do it
awesome
oh he is cloning himself to make
Troopers you want something done right
let's knock it in
I thought his pecks were bouncing I know
you gotta work them out don't open your
eyes
CGI face there yeah let's go a bunch of
naked moth Guardians
and I hope they have to fight them all
in the nude
where's that business or
we didn't have fresh drinking water in
yet here we had a beautiful underground
Oasis
your reinforcements have arrived
yeah buddy okay I still got a bad
feeling about it there's no way she's a
spy
let's take back our planet I do not
subscribed to this Theory
haha
hell yeah look at her go
I am flying I am the armor I am
aerodynamic
found it hey my man
leave that cool shot lead them
so
I'm so glad we get to live to see this
oh baby
badass shot
my ax
holy [__] it's like watching bees
dude this is pretty cool
she's a spy she's a bad one
oh wow
holy [__] that was awesome
here he is redoing what he did at the
end of season two
my clothes
we're finally going to be perfect
by adding the one thing I never had
that's what he's been trying to do when
Unstoppable Army you
smothered them before they could draw
their first breath
um oh no fascinating
come on grogu you got Force Powers take
him out
you just kill the dance man
oh
foreign
[Music]
seriously do something Kroger
I really should have held onto that dark
saber oh
bro goose
thank you
no no no no no no
oh my heart's racing right now
what the hell whoa what are you doing
they wouldn't
Roku dude you're training
oh my God
okay well we can just force them push
away don't worry they'll get the door
open and they'll just be crumpled in a
big red ball oh great shot wow
I'm kicking ass
[Music]
wow
what a boss
no
yes finally all right there we go watch
IG die twice
[Music]
do you know
God that can't feel good
it's like a robotic element to his armor
yeah well and like the hydraulic sounds
hell yeah
oh my God yes I've been saved by a woman
what the hell surrender
or fight
did he build it oh okay I thought he
built himself a light that's pretty cool
though I'll give him that
boy okay
oh
[Music]
this is Kroger's whole fighting okay yep
oh
hey
wow let's grab it jeez thank you
there's a straight up like a video game
oh my gosh
you're not gonna take my helmet off
hey bro
[Music]
dope the wickalorian yeah
Peggy I still owe you that dance
a little busy right now
whoa got him on the throat there almost
[Music]
ring
no that's all right there's a better
symbol than that to rule Mandalore oh
yes
mandalorians are weak once they lose
their trinkets the Mythos are just gonna
show up out of nowhere Mandalorian
stronger together
crash the ship right into him
right on off Gideon's head no but
actually though
wow there's some great aerial sequences
here it's terrific yeah that shot
beautiful effects work across the board
wow
it's the fire and particle Sims like
Jesus
oh
thank you Kroger crush his helmet
yes
sliding in
whoa
you mean his Armor's not fireproof he'll
come back with it melted to his skin or
something oh
[Music]
buddy look at this happy family
do it
it's a great shot I'm so glad they were
able to get the one ring to Mount Doom
[Music]
you have earned so many frogs little guy
ah they're gonna turn the great forward
John oh there
first words
maybe he'll ride the Mandalore I mean
the Mythos are I mean another I'll come
true
it's easy for season four at least I
need something he is too young to speak
so he is too young to take the Creed
his parents are far from here
if they're even alive
to say it then then I will adopt him as
my own
[Music]
Mandalorian Apprentice
take your Apprentice on his journeys
just as your teacher did for you
this is the way oh cool
he sees it yeah wake it up
HMS Titanic
[Music]
connected to the Mythic I'm liking this
foreshadowing
it's like kind of like Galaxy's Edge
wow
clap like normal people you've all got
hands
[Music]
what is this hat you don't have the
resources to protect the outer rim let
alone hunt down Imperial remnants
and I need work nice let me get this
straight
you want to work for the new Republic
on a case-by-case basis
it'll never get approved which is why
you won't tell them let me think about
it you already did
scrap assassin Droid head
I need it for parts
cabin just outside of town they load
with your new family if you choose some
between Adventures
you as well
Gina Carano all right she's back baby
amazing citizens
I am at your disposal and served at your
pleasure
everybody lives
I am din Skywalker
[Laughter]
thank you
all he needs is a guitar and we're set
I'm back to eating your little frogs
[Music]
what an interesting
there were no spies I didn't subscribe
to any of these spies theories no I
thought they were all ridiculous I think
I think our little Astromech friend was
the other spot I don't know there was no
other spot there was very little place
too much into that I was like it's just
a tally episode guys definitely got some
thoughts on this finale
definitely got some thoughts on the show
it was like a Marvel ending a little bit
a little bit
I I like that they've set themselves to
go back to their Roots there is no
post-crediting no it's about to start no
there's the book of Boba Fett is gonna
start
Star Wars
they just wanted to suffer you have to
respect the Deutsche they always hated
Star Wars
but no there it is it's loading in the
words of my best friend John oh campia
he says don't turn your speculation into
expectation good that's a bar and you
know what
I hope I hope people abided by that when
watching this episode because I can
imagine that Star Wars Theory right now
is yelling at his live stream while we
are filming this for sure there was an
extraordinary amount of payoff in this
episode you think so no
but bro said it would be completely
satisfying I was I was satisfied in the
sense that it was a beautiful visual
spectacle and while watching it I loved
every second of it and the minute that
it ended and I realized that I didn't
get any of the things that I was hoping
I'd get I was left with this fleeting
reminder that I am a Star Wars fan yeah
and this is this is just like the life
that we live yeah guys listen I never
subscribe I I never subscribe to the
whole there's a spy amongst this Theory
I thought that was just spies plural
plural correct it was just the episode
it was it's literally just the title of
the episode and it meant something there
and then everyone went read way too much
into it but who was the other spy will
mean something much further oh my God
everyone Let It Go listen I'm I think
they do that why don't we screw up last
couple years okay I think in season two
of tales of the Jedi I think that we'll
share some payoff to who that spot maybe
the Spy was Dave filoni in the Cantina
yeah no listen uh overall I still uh I
thought this episode was fine I thought
it was fun it was fun I think it's the
the weakest of the finales of all three
seasons I I felt
um no Stakes uh weirdly no stakes and
there was like fun visual spectacle and
yeah I think overall
to in my opinion and if you don't have
this opinion I am so happy for you my
opinion this is easily the weakest
season out of all three seasons of
Mandalorian uh I cannot uh I'm not I'm a
little surprised because it took a long
time for the season to come out I felt
like they've had a decent amount of time
to plan it I don't really know why this
one is the one that seems to have the
least type of emotional impact for me
maybe not for you
uh however I do think that this was just
a a fun predictable Road finale you like
this or it's just let's buy the numbers
as it can get and I did it there was
like no surprises other than okay they
advance that he's called din grogu now
Coupe cool uh I grow goo to me is I was
surprised by how
little he
can do I mean he came in with the fire
thing but I'm like you you did that in
the first season this is just a little
bit more
a little bit higher up there he didn't
immediately fall asleep afterwards he
just sat down so that's progress yeah
there's a lack of there's seriously a
lack of stakes for me here and
um we got some answers about why moth
was trying to get the Clones
cool even that just didn't do it for me
like yeah yeah like it was a mistake to
destroy all the clones and then fake us
out with another MAF Gideon death well
or kill him again either way yeah I
think it's a bit of a waste of so many
cool like so many cool poor tents when
you're in there and you're like oh man
this is his plan and he's I don't know I
guess these are the only ones he had and
he left this place completely abandoned
while he walked off to lure them you
know to him I don't know his yeah the
maneuvering of this plan on his end
didn't make the most sense to me if
those are the most precious thing on
this planet but definitely like straight
out of the like poor evil villain
Playbook of like oh I've captured you
but I'm gonna prolong your death and
tell you my evil master plan uh and then
it gets out uh yeah yeah I mean even Din
breaking out was like that to me was
such a wonderful high-stakes thing going
in where it's like oh great I
protagonist is in a genuinely precarious
situation or it's hard to imagine him
breaking out and that just felt like hey
yep immediately Sue season's in and and
uh the the the what were they in the um
in the in the second season the troopers
death Troopers yeah that's true the
death Troopers oh it's the same exact
thing only this time they didn't come
out of their
like robots yeah but this one they're
people in there yeah yeah they're just
it's it's a formula but the death
Troopers in the second season he had to
fight one and that was a struggle and
then scary and the thought of them all
breaking through when when they hit
before he had to eject them all into
space yeah that was that was more
intense just the suspense of them about
to break through yeah
anything with these Troopers is than
both of these episodes it is
surprisingly underwhelming and yeah they
reclaim Mandalore uh cool cool I can't
wait to see Boca Town lose it again uh
yeah just I'm I'm I would have been
totally content with us being like cool
look at all this work we put into
Navarro let's like
spend some time build some more susp
answers it's just more I think about it
the more I don't like it I'm not gonna
lie Yeah the more I think about it the
more I'm like whoa I'm leaning towards
this kind of sucked yeah it's very
jaggedly organized season
that just the the
inside of the Walt Disney Company at the
time of development for this season was
not in a great place and you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna write it off I think and
and I I say this with like nothing but
love and appreciation in my heart for
Star Wars
we know they can do better they gave us
like so many little nuggets of it this
season and in previous Seasons I think
they knocked it out of the park Once
Upon a Time this was your favorite Star
Wars show uh no I have none now
now you're a Mandalorian without a
planet
no I mean uh I I thought the battle to
reclaim Mandalore was epic and fun and
the calvary Collision of like the
mandalorians versus the Imperial
Commandos and jet packs was just like
visually it looked really cool it was
really cool but it has to be more than
that
um this felt the most cartoony this this
season felt other than a couple of
episodes this felt the most cartoony and
I know some people really like that
because it makes them think of Clone
Wars went to me this show was not Clone
Wars yeah I love Clone Wars but it's its
own this own thing it's an animated show
this is the the thing that separated
this was like the gritty westerns uh
Wi-Fi Bounty Hunter show and it doesn't
need to remain that uh but when you
literally have like
oh yeah the ending feels like they're
trying to course correct back to that
in in a way and I I would be curious to
know because I'm sure that that like the
way everything went down with dinjar and
grogu and and the whole Boba Fett
alley-oop of getting them back together
it feels like a machination from the
studio whereas like them retaking
Mandalore feels like a thing that that
could very well suit the show and yet it
also feels like just because of the way
things wrap up like a thing they kind of
had to do or something like I felt
nothing for them no yeah absolutely no
even like the four four Mandalore I was
like I should be crying right now like
as a Star Wars fan I've been waiting for
this moment for a long time and and it
just it was it was lacking the motion
the focus was off yeah as a whole it's
not hard to see from the beginning of
like where you're headed at the top of
the Season you know that reclaiming
Mandalore will be a huge thing and a
huge theme and as much as I very like if
you treated this more and I I feel like
it's a Trope to say this but more like a
Game of Thrones owns in the way that you
really realize the clashes of ideologies
and the scope and the space instead of
going like season six or seven style
where it's like we're just sipping
around action and stuff they really
bothered to make those debates and those
ideological clashes tangible and focus
that across all these episodes because
it does feel like there's like a chasm
in the Middle where like a bunch of
other stuff happens it's like episode
three uh that could have gone a lot
better in a more you know nuanced game
of thronesy kind of season not to say
that you shouldn't have some of that fun
I think that fun is I enjoyed episode
six a lot however yeah I feel like if
you really wanted to drive this Arc home
like this would be super meaningful and
you can still have DIN and grow Google
out on adventures afterwards but like
yeah it feels like something that got
relegated to a few episodes and because
it got relegated to a few episodes it
became let's just do the action Parts
yeah well I think
in one of the early episodes I made a
strange comparison to the same struggle
that The Walking Dead had from its early
Seasons to when all of a sudden it
wanted to be a Game of Thrones it wanted
to be bigger but it didn't feel earned
and it was executed very poorly and by
the time that you got done with it they
kind of killed the best part of the show
and you know I I think
and this is just absolute speculation
from like putting my producer cap on you
know I think the the master plan the The
Cinematic story event that they're
working towards when they were doing
seasons one and two I I think they were
just focused on making a good story I
think this season put a lot of pressure
to set those pieces in motion but the
story was very discombobulated and you
know I I know that they were supposed to
have Rangers of the new Republic which
would have helped supplement I I feel
like they asked this show to do a few
too many things uh while also just
breaking an otherwise wonderful formula
that uh was a refreshing return to why
people like Star Wars in the first place
yeah there's a lack of an emotional core
in this season
the biggest the biggest task feels
somehow very small yeah yeah there's no
catharsis there by the end I think it
might have been more interesting if
there was a because first it was like oh
we just can't inhabit this place because
it's like dangerous to be here uh it
would have been more rewarding if if the
obstacle was taking down Imperial
remnants that are occupying the
territory of Mandalore and that's the
hardest obstacle they have to overcome
yeah that way there's an actual
sometimes now it just feels like they
they got a place yeah when they already
had the whole thing with Navarro because
I know Mandalore means it's Mandalore so
of course it means something uh but no
they did there wasn't any true again
there wasn't any true type of emotional
payoff to it all but hey let's go
through some other [__] that happens in
here just one quick note
the and this is a Game of Thrones
spoiler when the darksaber was crushed
that reminded me of that same empty
fleeting feeling that I got when the
Iron Throne was melted like sure like
where I was like wow all this build up
and all this hype and we're just
and I was like over your shoulder maybe
the mythosaur like maybe there's
something here that when and
yeah they just treated that moment like
it was just another sword gun but I
guess they can repair it inside I
thought about the sword guys it's about
the person
working together
who is part Mandalorian and part Jedi
will build and not part Knight two and
part night of of of Jack Black of
Melissa that's right that's right let it
be known that is Canon and they will be
back ah God that well yeah we're all the
Allies we're I feel like we spent so
much time building a absurd cohort of
characters uh on your left moment yeah
well that's like at least give us like
uh that that portals they didn't really
do anything with moth Gideon they really
didn't he it was it felt very tacked on
yeah of
he's back again he's back again third
time in a row we're gonna we're gonna
fight him just like we did at the end
feed him and he's got it he's got a
stronger armor now and and the fight
with him and bow that should have been
very like there's there was no tension
there there really needed to like slow
down and simmer and this should be a
moment for Boca tan to fight again I
said it in two episodes ago like
contextually there was so much they
could have played with here yeah to just
slow it down make this episode 50
minutes instead of 40 uh and and that
way you could have some tension here so
that way when they fight like she lost
to him this is her revenge this is her
this is her reclaiming right now uh and
then they don't give it's just like a
fight season that happens no that's
exactly what it is and and it's it's
just really frustrating because
you this is a for for fans particularly
of Bo like this is a character build up
that's been going on for almost 10 plus
years now
um and to have that just fall absolutely
flat I mean I I keep thinking back to
like the bad badge season two finale
and they were able to create Stakes
whereas here there's a lot of characters
that I love there's a lot of things at
stake but just none of it landed no this
this this this season most part became
just it went from like
fine to lackluster to a to a couple of
things that I would love you know I love
like the second episode
last episode I loved yeah
um I always were fine
you said something a few episodes ago
Greg about how dingrich didn't crack it
correct uh yes uh
where
grego my eggo sorry uh
Everything feels fake it feels very
artificial I mean it it almost feels
like watching a fan film during some of
these episodes
last sequence in in the Cantina with
blue is just like I don't know I just it
felt so not
right now it's silly to say but like not
real yeah
um which is such a Divergence from the
first two seasons oh yeah the cinema
there's something about the
cinematography that is not like there's
a lot of cool visuals in this episode
but there's something about the
cinematography with the lighting that is
not visually striking anymore yeah and
it doesn't it doesn't breed a certain
type of atmosphere anymore yeah I'll
give them the I think the the aerial
combat stuff and especially for how hard
those effects can be did look beautiful
and I think definitely oftentimes Rick
family was the director who sells this
world the best to me
um but I I would agree like yeah this
season is sort of permeated by an
uncanny valley of some sort and I don't
know I mean for for me the way that
wrapped up with that whole fight and him
crashing the the you know ailing ship
into the ground and everything like that
sort of felt like it didn't really
amount to a heck of a lot other than
engulfing them in flaming and and with
which effect was not a great idea no I
mean I guess that it's like all you can
do when you're just crashing and you're
like maybe I'll just use this to my
advantage it's a big planet you know but
I hit that one hole I think it would
have been a stronger choice if they just
actually let moff Gideon get away like
instead of because it's either a fake
out again or he's just gonna be dead and
either way it feels yeah like a little
stunted right when this season he was
seeming to peek into you know like no
but he's still scary he's still
formidable commanding and like even on
the heels of this loss of all his clones
like where would that drive the
character so he was so is the
implication that moff was the first step
to snoke like this plan no so that's
that's the the the Lost opportunity I
mean in in the previous episode where
they talked about the shadow Council and
you had Hawks talking about operation
Necromancer that's snoke that's the he
just stole
one cloner and then decided to like make
four sensitive versions of himself which
would have also just been cool to see a
bunch of like you know and they could
have all been like messed up looking and
had like pseudo Force I mean there's so
many things you could have done but
instead we just got like the most milk
toast possible all it did was get an
answer to what was happening yeah and
even the answer was like kind of
perplexing
how long does he think until they turn
on him it's my first red that is an
illogical plan we've all seen them no
that's exactly what it is uh yeah I mean
I think there was a uh there was a
golden opportunity to let Gideon get
away and I what I had been holding on to
as a fan is something I think they've
they've hyped up thrawn in words so much
but we've yet to see anything that makes
him an actually like scary formidable
character in my version he would have
ridden off on the mythosaur I would have
just I mean that would break your heart
but that would be fascinating no
ah
no I I it would have been nice to see
thrawn you know
if if they're going to do an
introduction have him just like
effortlessly wipe Gideon off the map and
at least then like oh okay we're
replacing this one big bad with a bigger
blue bad per Marvel
um I don't I don't know I just I this
I'm not gonna lie this show this season
kind of ruined my love for these
characters
I lost a lot of my love that I feel when
I watched the show buddy for the
character no it's it's super fair I mean
I think they've gotta they've got a nice
setup you know I think uh with with din
jar and and in grogu go and do
admissions for the new Republic it opens
up to them going to the unknown regions
and you know playing a role in in the
Ahsoka story but I'm with you I'm yeah
this thought this this this is leaving
me a little dejected the more I think
about it the more it's the worse it just
gets in my mind
reacting to the first two seasons and
then re-watching it on my own
was like yeah I love this show I love
the first two I love the two episodes
that were only Mando focused and Boba
Fett more than most of the show this
season
yeah it does feel like it came from a
post Bobo yeah I was even thinking if
the mythosar showed up to save the dab
you're like like book above yeah
um but anyway as always next season Greg
uh so that sounds like they're course
correcting so that's that's the thing
about Star Wars fans we may be upset we
may be angry we might tweet our dismay
and and said not so veiled threats to
Executives at the Walt Disney Company
which you should not do
um but at the end of the day we keep
coming back because uh Star Wars is an
abusive relationship yes it is that's
just the way it is
all right guys well what did you think
did what was your favorite part there
was some beautiful visuals I want to
hear the optimistic upbeat side of the
Star Wars Community the reject Nation
Community is usually very optimistic
they're so happy I appreciate that uh do
we think lizzo is secretly a Jedi who
escaped Order 66 yes is Jack Black
actually one of them off Gideon clones
yes
yes find out next season on
the Mandalorian
which I which hurts my soul to say I
didn't it was it was okay it was all
right it was fine it's fine all right
guys
May the force be with you until the next
one guys
and thanks for being here Michael oh
thanks for having me Craig